Douanier Rousseau facteur cheval ou
professeur Tournesol monsieur Gaston qui
vit dans un petit village de la brille à
NES gilberg et tout cela et ses 80
printemps ne l'empêchent pas d'inventer
de découvrir sans cesse sa dernière
trouvaille est de taille et votre
récepteur de télévision sera bientôt bon
pour les oublier
alors maintenant je reçois de la Georgie
je reçois la télé pour sauver la
télévision la télévision par laser il y
a pas besoin de poste de TSF de
télévision alors maintenant les lasers
ils passent sans arrêt au-dessus de ma
maison et à l'intérieur ils sont
là-dedans alors je les vois les yeux
fermés alors vous voyez ça circule
de métal à la minute vers le nord oui
j'ai vu des vedettes rapides sur la
Volga ils étaient tous les de 30 à 50
mètres l'un derrière l'autre même
distance et se suivait et alors comme
j'étais sur ça a été pris sur un pont
alors je voyais les vedettes rapides il
passait souvent entre mes jambes mais
vous payez une redevance à la télévision
soviétique en paye rien pour ça c'est
gratuit c'est gratuit
à la télé à la radio j'ai vu des
techniciens russes des techniciens
américains tout ça mais
ne recevant pas encore la télé française
par ce procédé il a peint sur les murs
c'est peut-être préféré Jean Richard
Luis Mariano
Napoléon
Françoise dur Jacqueline cora et la
petite chèvre
ses baigneuses n'ont point besoin de se
sécher au soleil car la piscine exotique
fait entièrement de ses mains et tout
droit sorti d'un roman de Pierre Loti
n'a pas une seule goutte d'eau
tous les plantes vous voyez que vous
avez là dedans vous avez au moins plus
de 25 20 peut-être 23 ans de palmiers
les palmiers ont été achetés
le premier février l'année dernière
la cornemuse
s'est mise à marcher sans arrêt nuit et
jour et ça continue toujours
et on entend le son d'une cornemuse oui
on attend le centre de cornemuse et
quelques fois il y a des musiques
spéciales
ça vient dehors du matin et ça vient
d'Écosse directement directement
c'est fixé là maintenant c'est à
l'intérieur du mur là vous voyez c'est
fixé là et puis ça ne bouge plus et vous
écoutez des disques aussi de cornemuse
vous m'avez dit ben oui je vais j'en ai
acheté mais vous n'avez pas
l'électricité non mais vous avez quand
même le matériel ouais j'ai tout coucou
qu'est-ce que vous lui dites
[Musique]
Gaston comprend le langage des pigeons
et les pigeons lui répondent
qu'est-ce que vous faites
non il répond pas
non mais quand je prononce par exemple
la Suisse Bernard lassuce des Beaux-Arts
et Françoise dur vous m'avez dit
Françoise
et prenons ceci
j'ai la pile je voulais décrocher la
lune
maintenant elle peut plus monter ça fait
comme ça il est à gauche je vois un
appareil dans le temps c'est ça allait
il y a une bouche d'eau là-bas dans la
piscine elle tombe dans les cuillères
voyez j'ai fait des cuillères
et ça tourne et ça ça peut alimenter une
batterie quoi pour faire de
l'électricien de l'électricité
mais alors je l'ai enlevé de là-bas
parce que ça c'est plutôt gênant depuis
que j'ai tout ça la musique les la télé
tu sais machin là puis j'aurai encore
autre chose plus tard vous verrez pas ce
que je vais encore construire
alors j'avais encore d'autres choses
alors j'ai l'Écosse qui est là-bas
la Géorgie là-bas alors à plus tard ça
sera quoi tout ça sans électricité sans
rien vous êtes un homme heureux avec
toutes ces choses là oui mais je suis
tellement je suis tellement heureux que
des fois je m'endors et puis je laisse
tomber
au revoir cher Monsieur Gaston et soyez
heureux longtemps
très longtemps encore
[Musique]